hey this is presh to Walker
solve the following equation 81 to the
power sine squared X Plus 81 to the
power cosine squared x is equal to 30.
set the condition that X is greater than
or equal to zero degrees but less than
360 degrees
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
delightful equation to solve we'll start
by noticing that one of the exponents is
cosine squared x
we want to put things in terms of one
variable so we will use the equation
sine squared X plus cosine squared x is
equal to 1. we'll solve this for cosine
squared x by subtracting sine squared x
from both sides and now we'll substitute
into this exponent
so we have sine squared of X in one
exponent and 1 minus sine squared x in
the other exponent but let's further
simplify this
let's let U be equal to sine squared x
so the equation is then 81 to the power
of U plus 81 to the power of 1 minus U
is equal to 30.
since X is between 0 and 360 degrees U
will be between 0 and 1. so 81 to the
power of U will be greater than zero but
in particular it will not be equal to
zero so you always want to check this so
you're not dividing by zero so we can
rewrite this equation as 81 to the power
U plus 81 divided by 81 to the Power
view is equal to 30.
from here we will multiply both sides of
the equation by 81 to the power of U
again it's important we check that 81 to
the Power view is not equal to zero
otherwise we'll be multiplying both
sides of the equation by zero you don't
want to do that
so let's further simplify this equation
we'll distribute through on the left
hand side so we have 81 to the power of
2u plus 81 is equal to 30 multiplied by
81 to the power of U
we'll subtract 30 multiplied by 81 to
the Power view from both sides so we
have 81 to the power of 2u minus 30
multiplied by 81 to the Power view plus
81 is equal to 0. we'll make a further
substitution so that the equation will
be a little easier to understand let's
let V be equal to 81 to the power of U
so the equation is then V squared minus
30 V plus 81 is equal to 0.
so we've simplified this equation to a
quadratic and as it works out this
quadratic equation can be factored
we have V minus 3 multiplied by V minus
27 and that's equal to zero so this
gives us two solutions V is equal to 3
and V is equal to 27. so we'll just work
to get to X so we know that V is equal
to 81u so that means 3 is equal to 81u
and 27 is equal to 81u
to simplify further notice that 327 and
81 are all powers of 3. in particular 81
is equal to 3 to the power 4 and 27 is
equal to 3 to the power of 3. so we can
further simplify that 3 to the power of
1 is equal to 3 to the power of 4 raised
to U and 3 to the power of 3 is equal to
3 to the power 4 raised to the power of
U we can use exponent rules to simplify
so we multiply these exponents here and
now we can simplify this further
we have 3 to the one is equal to 3 to
the power of 4u and 3 to the power 3 is
equal to 3 to the power 4u so we want to
equate these exponents
so 1 is equal to 4u and 3 is equal to 4u
this gives that U is equal to one over
four and U is equal to 3 over 4.
so now we just need to transform back to
X so U is equal to sine squared x so
sine squared x is equal to 1 over 4 and
sine squared x is equal to 3 over 4.
taking the square root of both sides we
get sine X is equal to plus or minus one
half and sine X is equal to plus or
minus root 3 over 2.
as it works out these are special values
so we have our 30 60 90 right triangle
so sine of 30 degrees is equal to
one-half sine of 60 degrees is equal to
root 3 over 2.
so one solution sine X is equal to
one-half we have X is equal to 30
degrees
but we want to solve for x in the range
of 0 to 360 degrees
so let's draw a unit circle
here we have a triangle of 30 degrees
one angle and this is one value that X
is equal to 30 degrees but we could also
have this triangle with 30 degrees here
this will give the angle of 180 minus 30
degrees which is 150 degrees here we
have another triangle with 30 degrees
so we want the angle here which will be
180 plus 30 degrees and that will be
equal to 210 degrees finally we have
this triangle here so this angle will be
equal to 360 minus 30 degrees and that
is 330 degrees
so that's all the solutions to sine X is
equal to plus or minus one half
we can do the same thing for sine X is
equal to plus or minus root 3 over 2.
here we would have this angle equal to
60 degrees so the solutions would be 60
degrees 120 degrees 240 degrees and 300
degrees
and that's the answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a time